so uh david luke what
david lucas you know opens up for me on
the road savage [ __ ] roast master
he goes out he goes dude i love this i
can't believe
this he goes dude my boy is like super
connected in houston man he's gonna take
care of us
and he walks out the door i look at
chicago but i don't do
like after shows i just want to go back
to airbnb take my [ __ ] shoes off and
watch tv and rest
yeah and drink water and yeah hookah or
just hang out with you guys yeah i'm not
trying to go to the club
and we're all like no no this wants to
go i'm like we gotta tell david
something so we walk out there
awkward that's too awkward so we walk
out the right
the the guy he's like you know he's like
a ladies man he's like
oh my are you telling this he's like
he's dead and there's
three chicks one one you know lizzo
figure
girl the big girl yeah and then two
normal ones and he's talking he's like
yeah we're going this is some fancy club
in houston
he goes you you two can get in i can't
get your big ass in
and i'm i hear no he's straight upside
down girl
he goes i can't get her in that ain't
happening sweetheart i ain't getting a
big ass saying i was like
hey man he said the way we talked to him
he said he can't do it he said he said
a therapy and jim sessions could help
you out
i don't like that guy oh so so one was
awkward
so i don't like that so no no one does
so they will they would walk off and
like the girls were laughing on her and
i'm like what the so
i'm like we're good man and we get in
our cars they had like a escalade or
something first like
we're good we had a driver that used a
driver so we go back to airbnb
the next day one of those girls i
realized works at the club
and i went and found and said hey i want
you to i don't know that guy that guy
talked to your friend like that he's not
with us
you talk to your big fat friend like
that no that ain't cool
no that's what i said though the guy
you're talking about like that
that ain't that you're not gonna roll
here no i said this ain't gonna cut it
sweetheart
do you wanna talk your big fat friend
that ain't gonna cut it right don't let
that
not roll don't roll this where's it from
apparently you're you're you're a big
fat friend
big fat friend what are you calling
friends like it's a big fat why is it
just no i didn't tell her that i go hey
she's not
that guy has nothing to do with he's not
in our mouth no i know i said that too
and i goes your friend okay she goes oh
my gosh i stopped being friends with a
guy who said
he said this girl's a four uh ditcher
she was a friend of mine and the girl
was cool girl was what
what was she a phone to her face i
looked at her he said to her face yeah
and i said
or like like no no he said and i said to
him say who it was
no i'll tell you afterwards
oh yeah do i know the person but of
course i do and i said i said to him i
go i go dude in the you're the guy in
the movie i [ __ ] punched in the face
right oh
uh i never forgot it was never friends
with him again
but i never forgot i was like did you
ever face like you're before yeah and
i'd have to fight you man and i was like
hey dude you're the guy i punched in the
face in the in the movie i punch you in
the face and i keep punching in the face
too you're you're uh
i i was young and i you know i used to
lose my [ __ ] mind over stuff like
that i
hate that [ __ ] don't hurt people's
feelings man it's good
it makes me [ __ ] i don't like a bully
and i never you only didn't get me to
fight itself and that's why i said hey
your big fat friend don't worry about
her hey bro i brenden that's your best
friend
brendan if you were fat shaming no not
at all no but she was like no she
we laughed it off like i said joke i was
like he is a joke you don't have to
worry about he's a pimp
yeah sucks though